il
vu du ciel il trône au milieu du village
et de sa nature verdoyante
ces ruines du 12e siècle font face à des
tours du 13e
le château de meung-sur-loire ouvre ses
portes au public
l'occasion de redécouvrir ce condensé de
l'histoire architecturale française
c'est une très longue histoire avec les
avec d'orléans qui vont s'installer ici
avec un premier château un second
château qu'on voit derrière loire
jusqu'à la révolution française 1791
et puis après ça deviendra une propriété
privée quand vous vous promenez à
l'intérieur ses 800 ans en architecture
que vous pouvez voir depuis sa
réouverture le château fait le plus
grand plaisir de ses visiteurs
l'impression de redécouvrir la vraie vie
et tout ce qui fait le sel de la vie
on a besoin d'un peu de ressortir et de
oui-oui de ne reprendre l'air de voir
d'autres choses que notre quotidien
habituel et plus de se plonger dans
l'histoire aussi c
ils viennent d'autres régions de france
et même de l'étranger
nombreux sont ceux qui le redécouvre ou
qui le visitent pour la toute première
fois en et champenois et on est venus
passer le week end ici dans la loire
c'est patrimoine français moi j'aime
bien les jardins là en plus il fait beau
on a de la chance on vient du
département du doubs on est là pour
depuis vendredi ont fait le tour des
châteaux
j'essaie de récompenser un endroit et je
suis content de l'avoir visitée ajoute
n'est dans ces souterrains
le château de meung-sur-loire a aussi sa
part sombre de l'histoire alors les
anciennes prisons sont juste là bas
derrière moi c'est les entrailles du
château demain et là on imagine que
françois vision le poète a été incarcéré
parce que c'est cette prison pendant
sait rien elle était là en tout cas en
14 161 l'a priori c'est pas un bon
souvenir
à la fois mystérieux et majestueux
le château demain est un édifice aux
multiples facettes
en venant le visiter les touristes
participe également à sa restauration